let's go to five headlines
[Music]
let me tell you about um two-year-old
owen buell
and you could see him right there uh
owen has cancer stage four neuroblastoma
owen along with his family has been
staying at the ronald mcdonald house
near laurie children's hospital in
chicago
ronald mcdonald house was targeted by
looters and rioters during the riots a
few days ago
yes a place with cancer-stricken
children
um was attacked the the glass was
shattered door was shattered
to make matters worse owen was supposed
to go home to have his birthday party
and he just he just turned two this
little guy has earned his birthday party
more than
than than certainly i've ever earned in
a birthday party um
and he apparently is a big fan of llamas
who isn't i'm a big fan of llamas too
and so
his mom had a big three foot tall
stuffed llama
shipped to the house as part of the
birthday celebration she was looking
forward to bringing them home so you
could see that
um but the party had to be canceled
because of
the riots they couldn't discharge any
children in the middle of this
so owen missed his birthday party
meanwhile as
owen's mother describes it they could
hear just imagine
these children they could hear the
noises they could hear the the sirens
and the gunshots and everything and all
the chaos
and while they're trapped at this place
imagine the fear and the terror for
these kids who are already going through
something
that no kid should have to endure so
if you need another reason to despise
the rioters
and blm here it is just
reprehensible awful self-obsessed people
who don't give the slightest damn
about anyone but themselves remember
something
remember remember we played this
yesterday the blm activists
in chicago justifying looting by saying
that they should be able to take
whatever they want because they're
entitled to it let's play that again
i don't care if somebody decides to loot
a gucci
or a macy's or a nike because that makes
sure that that person eats
that makes sure that that person has
clothes that makes sure that that person
can make some kind of money because this
city obviously doesn't care about them
not only that that's reparations that is
reparations
anything they want to take take it
because these businesses have insurance
they're going to get their money back my
people aren't getting anything
so blm has taken whatever they want
because they're entitled to it
while cancer-stricken toddlers are
deprived
of their birthday parties because
it is a direct correlation because blm
had to take what it what it
is owed apparently um that meant that
cancer-stricken toddlers out of luck
by the way positive note here if you go
to my twitter right now i've got a link
up to the gofundme for um owen
and uh uh it's it's a gofundme for you
know
for of course his medical expenses and
whatever else the family
needs the money for and so you can go
there if you have it in if you're if
you're able to donate then do that we
i you know someone sent me the gofundme
page yesterday it had raised twenty
thousand dollars
uh when they sent it to me since
february
and then i put it up and we all kind of
rallied together and overnight
we doubled it to for another 20 000. um
so
go go to my twitter if you can and
donate there all right
the may the manager of a bakery in
chinatown was trying to talk to
mayor bill de blasio about how the
shutdowns and the coveted policies are
have affected have destroyed his
business
and he's getting quite emotional in this
clip understandably
but let's look at de blasio's response
to him watch
we've been taking a hit since january
we lost our chinese new year our busiest
day
of our community the most festive
holiday that we have
then now we're all part of the show
what we need is food and no margarita
everybody please step up
he just doesn't care uh at all speaking
of self-obsessed
not giving the slightest damn about
anybody but yourself there's
there's de blasio i mean de blasio the
rioters blm antifa
these are all match matches made in well
not heaven but
in the other direction anyway um
they're all they're all sort of peas in
a pod very very similar in that way he
just he doesn't care at all this guy's
this guy you know this this this
business owner
life business destroyed de blasio
couldn't couldn't possibly care less
just walks away from him
number three an article in the la times
uh here's the headline says want more
diversity in camping
start with the gear and then the article
goes into
detail talking about how fewer black
people go camping
uh and this you guessed it is due to
historical injustice and racism
you know all those laws on the books
forbidding black people from camping
it's
well you have to admit those laws would
be pretty bad if they existed
now i i and let me say i am totally
against those non-existent laws
i those laws don't exist and i say they
should continue not existing
now as for the question in the headline
i just thought i know it's a rhetorical
question i thought i'd answer it anyway
want more diversity in camping allow me
to answer that question no
i don't actually i don't want more
diversity in camping i also don't want i
don't i don't not want more diversity in
camping i don't want more i don't not
want more
i just have no feeling at all about the
racial makeup of the camping community
doesn't matter to me at all shouldn't
matter to anyone people will camp if
they want to
uh if they don't want to camp they won't
if more white people than black people
want to go camping
okay why would that matter
why does every single facet of society
need to
have a certain predetermined fill a
certain quota
you know a racial diversity quota who
cares
this something like camping as with so
many other things in in society
it really comes down to do people want
to do it or not it's like that with the
sexism claims and we'll talk about more
about this in a second
but we look at certain industries and we
say well there's not enough women doing
this job
have you ever thought that maybe there's
not more women doing the job because
women don't want to do that job
you know there's there's a lot of
there's not a lot of
gender diversity in the roofing
industry okay most roofers on a hot roof
in july
almost all of them men in fact i don't
think i've ever seen a female roofer
maybe a few of them exist
is that because females are excluded
from root from from roofing no it's just
because
they don't want to do it and so they
don't uh i suspect there's
something similar going on with camping
all right number four
huge news here finally we'll get to
something important farmers in botswana
have
come up with a uh an incredible
innovation they figured out that you can
prevent predators lions leopards that
are
from attacking your cows if you draw
eyes on the cow's
butt now you can see right here
eyes on the butt and they don't have to
be very realistic eyes either apparently
even these lackadaisical eyes will work
why do they work well
uh they've done a whole study to figure
out why this works i can tell you why it
works
would you want to eat a hamburger with
with eyes on it if you picked up your
hamburger
at applebee's and there's and there are
eyes
staring at you would you eat it i mean i
still would because i'm hungry but
it would freak me out no question uh all
i can say is that this
so far though is a massive missed
opportunity
if these if these farmers are drawing
eyes
i know you probably thought the same
thing as me right we're putting eyes on
the cow's butt okay i'm with you there
sounds good why aren't we putting googly
eyes
go to joanne fabrics if they have that
in botswana
get the googly eyes put that on the butt
of the cow
more realistic a lot funnier
let's go number five finally a new study
says that a certain mind controlling
fungus can infect cicadas and turn them
into zombies
and to be honest with you i'm really
just mentioning the story uh as an
excuse to transition into a story about
my kids this that's the only reason so
we're putting that to the side
enough about the cicadas uh i thought
this was pretty great
and i don't have anywhere else to put in
the show so i'm just going to tell you
here
i uh yesterday while i was out of the
house our our three-year-old
son got mad at his brother uh because
uh he wouldn't play with toys with him
so our three-year-old took one of the
toys
plastic shark threw it at his older
brother
hit him in the eye actually ended up
giving him a nice little cut beneath the
eye like right here
um and i guess my my younger son's logic
was listen if you don't want to play
with the toys with me
then i will beat you with them that was
his logic now
he got punished for that of course but
when i got home i decided that i should
have a a talk with him about it
and i was talking to him about it and i
asked him
why he did it even though i knew the
answer but i asked him anyway
and he told me this was his excuse all
right he told me
that he was worried that his older
brother might be a zombie
so he threw the toy at him that's what
he said
and you know i didn't expect his excuse
to be persuasive i knew he'd have some
excuse
i didn't expect it to be so persuasive
but i heard that and i thought
all right fair who
i mean who can what do you want him to
do he thought his brother was a zombie
or not even that see what i liked about
it was it wasn't he he didn't come out
and and outright accuse his brother
being a zombie he said
might be so so it was it was more of
like
a plausible theory that he couldn't rule
out
without further investigation and the
investigation involved
throwing a plastic shark at his eye i
don't totally understand the connection
there to be honest with you
but i don't have any experience battling
zombies do you so i don't think that we
can really pass any judgment there
and i thought that was that was good
kids will always kids are always coming
up with
it's one of the great joys of being a
parent is listening to all the
excuses from your kids i use the word
joy there are other descriptions you
could probably use but i'm going with
joy for right now
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content